let's get a little spicy hi my name is
Quincy my name is Fanny and I never
tried Taco Bell because I don't like
fast food this is my first time trying
to talk about because I live in Arizona
and we have like really good Mexican
food there I love Mexican food and my
favorite is ceviche and guacamole I kind
of just like bean burritos and soft
tacos my aunt Lacey she told me that the
crunch at supreme was really good I'm
very excited to see what we had for
today so this is the Doritos Locos Tacos
and I'm very excited to try it
mmm it's pretty good not that exciting
to be honest okay second Romo taco yeah
it tastes like a Dorito but it's not
anything special oh yes please
all right thank you let's get a little
spicy okay let's see I'm not the best
with hot stuff it's like not hot it's
like kind of like a little spicy I think
it's better without the hot sauce
overall this would probably not be my
favorite if I go to Taco Bell
I like Doritos but this doesn't taste
like a Dorito I mean I like to talk
overall but if I want to talk about I
would probably try something else so
this is the grunts wrap supreme and what
my aunt was talking about so I'm very
excited to try this I don't know it
looks like a sandwich with something
inside looks like a tortilla this was
better this is more like a Swedish tacos
I really like the sour cream there's
like sour cream lettuce that's the only
thing I can really like tasting it's you
know this is good
it's okay I'm not the biggest fan of
tomatoes but I can't really taste them
and then there's a tortilla I mainly can
taste that if I go to Taco Bell this is
something I could order for sure circle
it's a circle would ends I wasn't what I
thought it would be but I mean it was
okay but then I do have a question
where's the crunch is it a salad I don't
know how you guys like it so much
oh I think you got soft if I go to Taco
Bell
I can definitely honor it I'm not the
biggest fan of the Crunchwrap supreme
but let's see what we have next oh so
this is the Baja blast at Taco Bell I
guess that you can only get this at Taco
Bell so
Oh Mountain Dew Baja blast I never heard
of that
is it a soda tastes like Mountain Dew
almost like sprite like what it's
supposed to taste like
I mean it has a cool color but other
than done it's it tastes like sprite
like when I hear Baja blast that's what
sounds different it's like a tropical
mountain dew to me look if you're gonna
take pictures it was really look good in
a picture but other than that kind of
tastes like sprite I'll take this for
later this is the best thing that I've
gotten out of these items so far and I
like it so these are cinnamon twists and
I know this because I'm from Sweden and
we've seen them on but I grew up baking
cinnamon buns so let me see they look
like miniature oz it's a good I don't
know what to say it's not that good cuz
it's very crispy they just taste like a
churro but like kind of crunchy
Electro's these are good but it should
be softer like a muffin or the one I
tried from Domino's or softer and that's
actually a little better these are too
crispy a dessert shouldn't be this
crispy this is more like a snack and a
snack should be more salty so I like
these better than the regular churros
and if you guys haven't tried them you
should if I go to Taco Bell I might
order these because it tastes in a month
but not as good as cinnamon buns these
are good but I think with Baja blast
beats it the Crunchwrap supreme was
pretty good cuz a sour cream I like sour
cream in tacos this is my favorite drink
it's really good and actually I don't
like Mountain Dew but I really like this
Doritos Locos Tacos was nothing special
and my least favorite thing Torito Loker
took taco I will go back just for the
Crunchwrap supreme cuz that was good and
I would definitely go back for the Baja
blast
the cinnamon twist
[Music]